معالي الوزير بلينكين هل لديك دليل على
أن إيران وجهت هذا
الهجوم هناك علاقة طويلة
بين إيران وحماس في الواقع حماس
لم تكن لتتواجد أه على هذا النحو لولا
الدعم الذي
تتلقاه من إيران على مر السنين في
هذه الحالة تحديدا أه  لم
نر بعد أه دليل على أن إيران وجهت
أو كانت وراء هذا الهجوم بالذات ولكن
أه بالتأكيد هناك علاقة طويلة
وهي أحد الأسباب التي جعلتنا
نتخذ إجراءات حازمة ضد إيران
ودعمها للإرهابيين ووكلاء
الإرهاب أه والجماعات الأخرى
على  أه في السنوات القليلة الماضية لهذه
الإدارة قمنا بفرض عقوبات على أكثر
من 400 فرد
وكيان إيراني على وجه التحديد بسبب
دعمهم لأشياء مثل حماس بينما
نتحدث عن إيران، علي فقط أه أن
أطلب منك ذلك إذا كنت تريد الرد  إلى
ما نسمعه من الجمهوريين الذين
مرارا وتكرارا أه منذ أن حدث هذا
يستخدمون كلمة استرضاء عندما يتعلق الأمر
بإيران وإدارتك
انتقدوا قرار فك تجميد 6
مليارات دولار من الأموال الإيرانية التي أعرفها وأريد
أن أذكر أن تلك الأموال وفقا  إلى
إدارتك لم يتم
فك التجميد بعد، إيران لم تقم بذلك بعد،
ولكن الاتهام هو أن
موقف إيران معذرة، إن موقف الولايات المتحدة
إدارتك تجاه إيران
ساعد في المساهمة في هذا، أريد أن
أعطيك فرصة
للرد بشكل جيد  هناك شيئان هنا
أولاً فيما يتعلق بأه الأموال
التي ذكرتها أه والتي
تم الإفراج عنها تم
إتاحتها لإيران
لأغراض إنسانية كجزء من أه إعادة الأمريكيين
المحتجزين والمعتقلين في
إيران لنكن واضحين جدًا بشأن  هذا ومن
المؤسف للغاية أن البعض
يمارس السياسة في حين أن الكثير من الأرواح قد
فقدت وإسرائيل لا تزال تتعرض
للهجوم، الحقائق هي أن
أموال دافعي الضرائب الأمريكيين لم تكن متورطة هذه
كانت موارد إيرانية أه أه إيران
تراكمت من بيع نفطها
أه ذلك  كانوا عالقين في أحد البنوك في
كوريا الجنوبية كان لديهم منذ اليوم الأول بموجب
قانوننا بموجب عقوباتنا الحق في
استخدام هذه الأموال
لأغراض إنسانية، وقد تم نقلهم من
حساب أه إلى آخر في بلد آخر
لتسهيل هذا الاستخدام حتى الآن ليس
تم إنفاق دولار واحد أه أه
من هذا الحساب ومرة ​​أخرى أه
يتم تنظيم الحساب عن كثب من قبل
وزارة الخزانة الأمريكية لذلك لا يمكن
استخدامه إلا لأشياء مثل الغذاء والدواء أه
المعدات الطبية هذا هو ما يدور
حوله الأمر وبالمناسبة
الإدارة السابقة  إنشاء آلية بسيطة للغاية
لتمكين إيران من استخدام
عائداتها النفطية التي تم حظرها في
أماكن مختلفة أو العالقة في
أماكن مختلفة لأغراض إنسانية، لذلك
إما أن يتم تضليل الناس أو أنهم يقومون
بتضليلهم وفي كلتا الحالتين يكون الأمر خاطئًا
قبل أن أتركك تذهب.  أريد أن أسألك
عن قول الأمم المتحدة إنها
رصدت صواريخ قادمة من
لبنان باتجاه إسرائيل وأن حزب الله
يتبنى المسؤولية هل رأيت
معلومات استخباراتية أه أن حزب الله
يفكر في هجوم هجومي أكثر
في شمال إسرائيل وربما
حتى يحصل  المساعدة من مجموعات مثل
طالبان أو إيران كما تحدثنا
جيدًا، أحد الأسباب التي
جعلت الرئيس بايدن واضحًا جدًا منذ أه
اللحظات الأولى أنه لا ينبغي لأحد أه في أي مكان آخر أن
يحاول الاستفادة من هذا
الوضع أه على وجه التحديد أن يفعل
كل شيء  يمكننا أن نضمن أه
ليس هناك جبهة أخرى في هذا
الصراع بما في ذلك حزب الله ولبنان
أه رأينا بعض إطلاق أه محدود
لصواريخ أه قادمة من
لبنان باتجاه إسرائيل يبدو أه في
الوقت الحالي قد أوقف
رد الإسرائيليين أه على الفور أه  وحتى
الآن أه هذا هادئ ولكنه شيء
نراقبه بعناية شديدة